le leader de la france un sou il était
dans l'île le week-end dernier nous
posons ce soir un autre regard sur cette
visite du marché de sainte marie au
meeting de saint-andré notre long format
est signée jean marc collienne laurent
figo et marie redortiers c'est ici au
marché de sainte marie que jean luc
mélenchon a vécu sans doute la séquence
pendant laquelle il a été le plus au
contact de la population réunionnaise
pendant sa visite
et c'est ici que nous le retrouvons en
compagnie des députés omar j ai
maintenant la visite de jean luc
mélenchon à la réunion c'est d'abord une
histoire de carottes
alors combien ça vaut la barre haut de
plus qu'eux
les carottes apporter de chine et vendus
moins chers que les carottes pays
jean luc mélenchon n'en revient pas
parce que franchement j'ai une carotte
et on à la carotte d'australie et encore
ça alors là pour le prochain
une histoire tellement folle que jean
luc mélenchon va s'en servir pour
expliquer la situation réunionnaise aux
médias nationaux
bonjour écoutez je vais vous faire une
petite démonstration
je vais vous expliquer pourquoi tout à
travers
pas seulement une carotte à me passer
mans une carotte
regardez ça là celle-là elle vient de
chine regardez en 50 et là on la plante
ici elle vaut 2 euros le kilo
est ce que vous trouvez normal comment
voulez vous à partir de là qu'on arrive
à faire vers une agriculture et demandé
aux gens de travailler ici est de
planter des carottes
si vous voulez bien y réfléchir c'est
pas seulement la concurrence qui est
absurde c'est surtout de cette touche
carottes et bien en avion vous vous
rendez compte et voyages en avion faire
voyager en avion une carotte pour
qu'elles arrivent ici moins cher
une carotte produits dedans comme très
pas que c'est une histoire de fou et
pendant ce temps là des réunionnais que
fabre et léger en avion pour aller à la
métropole parce que c'est un prix
incroyable
non vraiment ce monde est fou et faut
remettre de l'ordre allez
madame si vous ne filmez vous nous voyez
pas bonjour
oui à vous voir vous entendre on a
l'impression que vous êtes encore déjà
ah bah écoutez avec moi bonjour chez la
compagnie de la prochaine sélection
c'est dans cinq ans quand même oui mais
il faut lé contenu du message que nous
portons
on doit se donner du temps pour en
convaincre pour que ça pénètre en
profondeur parce que comme c'est bien
normal dans une démocratie un tout le
monde était d'accord avec vous nous
savons que notre programme de toute
façon arrivera au pouvoir en france
maintenant c'est plus une question de
temps et il faut qu'à ce moment là il ya
une opinion publique bien construite
bien consciente
parce que sinon ça le fera pas car
compte tenu de ce qu'il a à faire
si c'est possible je veux y aller ça
bouge un peu de mon ex et non il ya par
ici
on aurait cru que vous aimiez le piment
[Musique]
c'est pourquoi je mens ou brûlés
prochaine à ma caricature puisque vous
voulez mais si vous assure une petite
pente bio divine et que vous aviez binek
de citron tous les 6 mois médicinales et
confitures pays les presque bionique
[Rires]
c'est mon jour mais tout le monde n'est
pas aussi enthousiaste ce bazardiers
avoue qu'il ne croit plus aux promesses
des politiciens
cette fois c'est jean hugues ratenon qui
se charge de lui répondre se trompe
souvent mais la prochaine fois faut pas
se tromper
la prochaine fois c'est l'ami en commun
monsieur il faut garder confiance ce
match fut pas de changer il va pas
changer à coins du monde
j'entendais changer le nez on les laisse
vous le mien voit les gens là ils ont
l'impression que je leur dis tout le
temps des choses istres a jamais rien
alors à la fin c'est c'est à la fin ça
donne du le dégage in c'est ça c'est les
gens qui vivent là vous servez à rien
dégager assez bu taille et d'une finesse
sa copine vient aussi des gens qui
disent ah
c'est normal c'est le bloc ont raison
fait par nous c'est pas à nous de dire
mais non mais non
[Musique]
il est 17h case et jean luc mélenchon
arrive pour le grand rendez vous de sa
visite à la réunion son meeting ici à
saint-andré
[Applaudissements]
et c'est parti pour une heure de
discours avec toujours le même refrain
proche de la méthode coué
nous serons bientôt au pouvoir et il
faut s'y préparer on fera pas toujours
il des macros léo l'ordre des sarkozy et
tout ça qui nous emballe dans du papier
différents la même marchandise camille 2
qui n'a jamais marché nulle part qui ne
fonctionne rien de bond pour faire de la
misère partout dans le monde y a traduit
le prix du riz
[Applaudissements]
et vous
il est beau
être français c'est pas une couleur de
peau c'est pas une religion
j'ai pas un village est le ventre et
j'ai adhéré du fond de soi-même en
direction de tous les êtres humains
un programme commandes d'humanité
liberté égalité
[Applaudissements]
la journée est terminée les militants et
les bénévoles de la france a soumises
sont réunis devant le restaurant de
champ-borne à saint-andré et jean luc
mélenchon a promis de venir les saluer
dans un instant
et ici je viens travailler qui est
important c'est qu'on ait une sorte de
perfectionnisme dans le travail leur
action parce que ça nous donne une
grande efficacité de travail ça
économise la porte
c'est magique pour affaires
et en attendant le grand soir la journée
s'achève par quelques samoussas une
dernière photo et un dernier clip hier
autour du grand chef
[Musique]